welcome to The Gadget Lab show I'm
Michael colori I'm Nathan only about his
Giles what is this you taking a call
what's going on no I'm not calling my
mom this these white headphones are
actually from Samsung not Apple even
though they look exactly like Apple they
do look exactly like iPhones and they're
connected to this the Samsung muse which
is a new $50 mp3 player from our good
friends at samson interesting a
fifty-dollar mp3 player without a touch
screen no touch screen that sounds a lot
like the ipod shuffle I think that's
what it's called yet another fifty
dollar three player that conveniently
clips on to you know your pocket are you
sure or whatever it's cool so it's it's
for android right yeah yeah basically
this is the ipod shuffle for android
lovers is kind of the idea anyways it
should sync to your Galaxy s3 any
Samsung smartphone that you have and
well just about most android phones okay
you know that's what they claim that's
what they claim and you have a samsung
phone here doesn't actually work that
easy yeah yes this is the galaxy s3 now
granted it is running cm10 so it's not
actually touch with android but i have
plugged it in to the s3 using this
really kind of obnoxious dongle this is
how you connect it yeah that's how you
connect it you connect that side into
the headphone jack the other side goes
into the micro USB port on the phone and
then an app launches then you should be
able to sync everything but with cm10
anyways it only syncs the first time
that you plug it in after that it won't
recognize the muse anymore it says if
the device isn't connected now you've
also tested this on other android phones
right other nons yeah the HTC one x+ the
droid razr HD and the nexus 4 and it
work with any of those on the app okay
which is a pain and even when you do get
to sync it won't recognize the music did
you have google play which is where i
store most my music okay um but if you
download from amazon it'll it'll work
fine there so you can only load music
onto it that you've loaded onto your
phone from your pc yes or music that
you're loading from your phone onto the
device that you have previously loaded
onto your pc yes yeah exactly as
complicated that sounds so the only way
i've been able to get music on the news
so far has been on the imac oh my
goodness so plug in here get on imac put
on music how much storage does have four
gigs forget it okay so why would i buy
this instead of buying an ipod because
you really really really love this
smooth little pebble look this like
purple another samsung you just hate
apple you just hate apple ID i mean i
don't know i mean maybe that would be
the reason i mean if you have the ipod
shuffle it's not going to sync with your
mobile device anyways yeah and this one
syncs with your mobile device like ten
percent of times for me and testing so
far no shame I mean is the only reason
why you'd even be interested in
something this small and unused friendly
is because you really want to listen to
music not on your phone because your
primary music player nowadays yeah we
probably your fault and you're not gonna
go for like a 10 mile run no I mean you
could but this is much more convenient
for going for a time yes so you know
what if you're that dedicated and you
really really want it sync it to your pc
forget the phone equation uh I don't
know but no this is not this is not the
pebble I was looking for this is not
abused the ipod stuff falling for you
know what'd be great is like NFC yeah in
the future i know you got it in your
samsung yes isn't this isn't this isn't
the one all right well it's not too bad
just yet another poor mp3 player that
doesn't exactly work as advertised I
think a lot of people forget is most of
this happens on the software side yes
and if you can't get the software your
device is useless yeah and it's good
hardware it looks good it works good it
sounds good it just we have some
software I didn't mean to imply say
useless when I pointed at that
that's just not it's not you wake him
out it's a great doesn't have to be a
player as long as you have a computer
and a lot of patience all you have is a
phone okay well we have to move on we're
gonna bring on Robbie and he's going to
show us some really cool technology
heavy goggles for skiing and
snowboarding for the winter all right
Robbie's here hi what do you got there
rubbing I have the oakley airwave
goggles now these have the recon
instruments heads-up display which isn't
really like you know heads up like you
see in like f-14s or in cars it's
actually a tiny little display and it
sits inside here 14 yeah so it's a
little screen like what does it feel
thank you so tell you how fast you're
going which is nice once you hit about
35 no you'll stop looking down but i'll
give you that your maxspeed i'll give
you air term if you're doing a lot of
jumps it'll track your you know your
your GPS as you're going down the hill
so it's pretty cool for that this video
altitude like changing say like how high
you are I'll tell you that your vertical
drop while you're you know snowboarding
or skiing so if you're a big data hand
our dad ahead or whatever these are
really cool it also it's Bluetooth
enabled so it works with your smartphone
android iOS webos so we're site you can
control your music with it just really
cool now there is something that's
supposed to be coming it's it's not out
yet what's there is an update coming
where you can see text messages oh so if
your friend text messages you can say he
could say hey I met you know the lodge
come meet me at all cool but can you get
all is it going to allow you to get
notifications from other services to you
like Twitter and things like that like
if somebody tweets I think so I mean I
haven't had a chance to test napkins not
out yet so you never really know what
this stuff but if you have another
friend who can afford the six hundred
dollars for these thing that's a lot of
money but if you have another friend it
has this you guys can track each other o
Sole on the mountain find your buddy on
yeah you can sneak in like kind of as
you turn you can see ok there's the
lodge here's a run there's just like
little lines on a compass and their
other my buddy you know Frank and you
just go is it does it put like a little
box around their head like in in
video game yeah oh it's a little arrow
oh rank that'd be super cool cuz it'd be
like locking you know your your cruise
missile on under whatever your eat see I
German like the Terminator yeah my
biggest complaint is the price that 600
bucks a lot of money first some some
headphones are not some headphones but
uh some goggles for goggles and they
still suffer from the same problem the
first recon instruments enabled goggles
has which is you lose some peripheral
vision like you know you're you can't
see like this much and I do a lot of
tree writing which means I ride in trees
and I want to be able to see you know
how close the tree is so that's that's a
bit of a bummer well we should mention
that recon has partnered with not only
oakley but like Smith Scott they do
thanks yeah there's a budget for company
and they all kind of have that same
problem remember we looked at a bunch of
different models with recons heads-up
display technology in it and they all
have that sort of lack of peripheral
vision yeah just kids yet you have to
build in the little monitor and all this
system and they're all right around the
same price too they're all like well
over five hundred five hundred dollars
yeah but you know these are oakley
goggles so you know they're they're good
oakley just makes amazing goggles you
not to worry about any of you know
distortion or anything on the lenses but
we actually wore them on the mountain
last week we went snowboarding for four
days up in Lake Tahoe and wore them and
Robbie was quite impressed by them so
much so that he still has them I still
have them I need to send them back okay
thank you for that we'll have more a
crazy ski and snowboard technology as
the winner moves on and we will see you
next week on The Gadget Lab show bye